en la madrugada de este 5 de julio dos
aviones especiales aterrizaron en suelo
francés a bordo 16 mujeres ya listas y
35 en niños todos repatriados de los
campos de detención del noreste de siria
se trata de la mayor operación de
repatriación realizada por las
autoridades francesas y para las
familias es una satisfacción
estoy muy muy contento aunque mi hija no
forma parte de las repatriaciones
es un gran un gran placer una gran
satisfacción ver que francia da por fin
hilo de 180 grados que la razón se
impone
inmediatamente después del aterrizaje
las madres y los niños fueron separados
las mujeres fueron detenidas y los
menores quedaron a cargo de las
autoridades de protección de la infancia
tendrán que pasar por un largo proceso
de evaluación sanitaria y psicológica
antes de ser recibidos por familias de
acogida y supervisados por los servicios
de protección judicial de los niños esta
repatriación colectiva supone una
ruptura con la política adoptada hasta
ahora por parís que consistía en
devolver al territorio francés a niños
sin sus madres es decir huérfanos o
niños cuyas madres aceptaron firmar un
documento de renuncia a sus derechos
como madres entre los países europeos
que cuentan unos cinco mil nacionales
que se incorporaron al autodenominado
estado islámico entre 2013 y 2017
francia quedó cada vez más aislada pero
su negativa a repatriar a sus ciudadanos
estaba volviendo
ya que todas las ong de derechos humanos
como amnistía internacional y human
rightswatch la condena van denunciando
condiciones inhumanas en los campos de
siria antes de la repatriación del
martes unas 80 mujeres ya listas y 200
niños franceses seguían detenidos en los
campos del noreste de siria